good morning good morning 6 25 on your
friday morning truck traffic and
turn signals up where the 95 meets the
northern 215 beltway we're going
centennial polling
so a viewer who likes to call herself
northwest mom writes can you please help
me understand why the turn signal at the
exit from the south 95 to android has
only one left turn lane
but the exit from north 95 at anne road
has two
left turn lanes she writes there are a
lot of construction trucks exiting the
southbound side
meaning cars get stuck sitting through
multiple lights
she says some drivers are turning left
out of that middle lane which is
designed to go straight back onto the
freeway
she writes someone's going to get into a
serious accident well you know what that
sounds frustrating and definitely
dangerous mom nevada department of
transportation's tony ilia tells me a
lot of that truck traffic probably is
connected to the ongoing work for the
centennial bulls final phase
and tony adds although there are no
current plans to alter that specific
interchange
we're hopeful that completion of the
project in mid-2024
will improve all traffic flows through
the northwest quarter obviously that
doesn't do much for you today mom but i
will pass your concerns about the
frustrated illegal turns along to the
nevada highway patrol thanks for writing
in
buckle up drive carefully please put on
that phone if there's something driving
you crazy email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com